I
PART OF  TO B I OF
AND THERE IS
RE
BIG THREAT,TMENT WILL AROUND.
EEN
HOURS.NDTOSIN ERA WAR?
>> Rep 6,000
R ONeporter: SAT IS ENOUGH
VISITORS.
OVERNMENUILDING BUNKERS HERE196
5.>> DEEPER ANDEEPER
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: BUT THE SCALE OF IT
NOE ISME O T
PUBLIC.
WHTHIS
AR WITH ASP, MYDNCHE TO OFFSE
>>O THISE E OF
OF THSHELTE
>> Reporter: SO SPORTS
HOLES AR BY SMALLE
r: AND A
POSSIBLYHE SES.
ter: LIK S
E
WOW.IMMIST ALEOOeZE
T E WIPUE ARRIER,
NT2 BILLLD BEDROOOIF THERE IS CS
HERE SAFE?
NOW PARK.OUH, TKEHE MOST
P
>> Reporter: AGAIN.
>> AGAIN.
RT IS
IT IS A CAR EOUR  NEXT MI YE
RSeporter: ANDORE WE
OWSHELTE.
EXPLOSIVES IN ITBL
>>ep.
IC.
AND IS THAGHT SOLUTELYASCINATING
E STS HERE.R
T Y HA JOIS N
GEN INLLRLD THERE AT YOU ARE SHK
WHAT ARE THE FOREIGN MINISRSTHA
AS WELL
NLAND IS ONE OF A
E ATCOK FOR THAT EXTENSION IN
JUST ALLUDG .E OF THE THING
S O SAID
THROUGH R NGORNING IS THAT THEA
R NATO ND IS
INL THT
NE TY E RURE ANGRY
ING TOE
TIO  NATO,S AND VLADIMIR
BLAME.
THEY S T IS AN AS WELLINTO ENHA
TY
POEN TO WH TSTER SAID ASARRIVED
RATIFICATION PROCESS AND
COHIS AS
WES AN IMPORTA
PART, AT'T B
,  IO DECIDIJOIN,
THEY J QUICKLY.
epLY
RSE THSTILL  MOR
THAT TO BE T
TURKS.
SEEMS TO BE  SAYINOUT SWNLANINIY
THATE ACES ARE A SAFE HAVENS ITE
SAYING THAGHT
NONOT TH
QUITG TO HEAR
BECAAS- WE  THIS INR E MEET
MOST OF THE FOREIGN MINIST
HA COULDIED TO ASK THE TSHREIGNE
BUT S STILL OULD BK  TT
NATIONS
PSILIEVE  ANDLL BECOME TANT
FINLANFOSECONDFOIN
ANOTO EXPRESS THEISO RSIONCRETEE
HEINHEY
WANTHAIN NATO.
WITHIN THENCE, TWORKING ON RIG
LICT REGIOT BORDERRA.IAN VIOUSL
CLOSE TO THE
BORDWI.
CERNEDEN Y H
EIBO
EARING SOME OFE RHETG OUOF
MOSCOW.
SO WHAT NA